THOSE MOMENTS WHERE WE'RE
YUKKING IT UP. WE'RE HAVING
FUN AND THEN WE HAVE TO DO
AND GET SERIOUS THE DESHAUN
WATSON CASE STILL PERCOLATING
SOME DEVELOPMENTS TODAY AT
ONCE AGAIN. WE'RE ONLY GOING
TO TALK ABOUT IT WHEN THERE'S
NEWS. WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO
OUT OF OUR WAY TO TALK ABOUT
IT. WE'D RATHER NOT TALK
ABOUT IT.
WE'D RATHER NOT TALK ABOUT
IT. I'D RATHER IT HAVE
OR HAPPENED. I'D RATHER THAT
THESE INCIDENTS THAT UNDERPIN
THE 22 LAWSUITS AGAINST
DESHAUN WATSON, AND NOW AT
LEAST TWO INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE GONE TO THE POLICE HAD
NEVER OCCURRED WHATEVER
MOMENTS. I WISH THAT THOSE
THINGS HAD NEVER EVEN HAD THE
OCCASION TO OCCUR THAT WE
WOULDN'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DISCUSS THIS FOR A MINUTE OR
A SECOND. BUT HERE WE ARE AND
TODAY WHAT HAPPENED WAS FOR
THE FIRST TIME TO SEAN WATSON
THROUGH HIS LAWYER RUSTY
HARDENED ANSWERED ONE OF THE
CASES IN COURT WITH A
STRATEGY THAT I BELIEVE WILL
APPLY TO ALL OF THE CASES
EXCEPT THE TO WHERE WE NOW
KNOW THE NAMES OF PLAINTIFFS
THAT WOULD LEAVE 20 CASES
WHERE THE PLAINTIFF IS.
PROCEEDING UNDER THE JANE DOE
PSEUDONYM AN EFFORT BY
DESHAUN WATSON TO GET THE
CASE IS DISMISSED UNLESS THE
INDIVIDUALS ATTACH THEIR
NAMES TO IT. IT'S NOT A VERY
COMPLICATED HIGH-END LEGAL
ARGUMENT. IT'S BASED ON THE
TEXAS RULES OF CIVIL
PROCEDURE AND THE ARGUMENT IS
ONLY MINOR CHILDREN CAN
PROCEED WITH PSEUDONYMS AS
PLAINTIFFS. YOU HAVE TO GIVE
ENOUGH INFORMATION IN A
LAWSUIT. SO THE PERSON KNOWS
WHO IS SUING THEM IN THE SAD
COMMENTARY AND ALL OF THIS.
MILES FRANKLY. I NOTICED
SEAN'S WATSON'S CAMP ISN'T
REAL THRILLED ABOUT THIS
POINT BEING MADE, BUT THE
IS THE GUYS HAD SO MANY
PRIVATE MASSAGES OF THE
COURSE OF THE LAST TWO YEARS.
HE CAN'T FIGURE OUT WHO THE
PEOPLE ARE. HE CAN'T KEEP
TRACK. HE'S HAD SO MANY HE
DOESN'T KNOW WHO'S SUING HIM
BECAUSE HE HAD SO MANY
MASSAGES OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS. HE CAN'T PIECE IT ALL
BACK TOGETHER AGAIN. SO LOOK,
I THOUGHT THIS WAS GOING TO
BE THE APPROACH AND THIS IS
JUST THE FIRST STEP IN WHAT
COULD BE A LONG AND
CONVOLUTED AND DRAWN-OUT
PROCESS.
YES, BUT YEAH FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS WHOSE NAMES
RUSTY HARDEN ON BEHALF OF
DESHAUN WATSON TRYING TO GET
THE NAMES TO BE RELEASED.
YEAH, I THINK WHAT YOU THE
POINT THAT YOU JUST MADE THAT
DESHAUN WATSON SAID SO MANY
MASSEUSES THAT HE CAN'T
FIGURE OUT WHICH ONES THEY
ARE. I MEAN THEY'VE BEEN ABLE
TO IDENTIFY 18 THAT AT LEAST
WERE ABLE TO SPEAK IN FAVOUR
OF DESHAUN WATSON WITH THAT
STATEMENT THAT WAS RELEASED
OR THE STATEMENTS. I SHOULD
SAY THAT WE RELEASED LAST
WEEK, BUT THEN YOU ADD THAT
TO THE 22 THAT WE ALREADY
UM, JANE DOE AND NOW WE HAVE
AT LEAST 40 CASES OF HIM
GETTING PRIVATE MASSAGES. SO
THAT'S THE ONLY ONES THAT WE
KNOW OF RIGHT? I'M SURE THERE
COULD BE MORE INDIVIDUALS OUT
THERE. SO BUT WE'RE ALREADY
AT UPWARDS OF 40 AND SO ONCE
YOU START GETTING INTO THAT
TERRITORY, IT REALLY FEELS
LIKE IT'S AN ALMOST UNHEARD
OF SITUATION FOR A
PROFESSIONAL ATHLETE TO GO TO
THAT MANY DIFFERENT FOLKS
JUST TO GET A MASSAGE THAT I
THINK IS I AGREE WITH YOU
MIKE. JUST ONE OF THESE WE'RE
DONE FOR
AND IT THINGS THAT ARE COMING
OUT FROM THE SEAN WATSON'S
CAMPUS. IT'S JUST AN
UNINTENDED POINT THAT THEY
OBVIOUSLY ARE MAKING BECAUSE
THIS IS THE THING THAT IS NOW
OUT THERE AND THIS IS WHAT
THEY HAVE TO CONTEND WITH IN
ORDER TO START TO GET THESE
CASES RESOLVED. THERE WILL BE
ONE OR MORE HEARINGS TOMORROW
MORNING ON THE EMERGENCY
PETITION TO HAVE THESE
INDIVIDUALS NAMED AND I
FRANKLY THINK THAT WHAT THE
STRATEGY HERE IS BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT TO GET TOO DEEP
INTO THE LEGAL WEEDS, BUT YOU
DON'T HAVE TO HAVE AN
EMERGENCY.
HEARING YOU JUST FILE A
RESPONSE TO THE COMPLAINT IN
EVERY CASE SAYING WE ASK THAT
THE CASE BE DISMISSED UNLESS
THE INDIVIDUAL IDENTIFY HER
NAME, BUT THAT WOULD TAKE
SOME TIME TO PLAY OUT. THAT
WOULD BE A BRIEF SUBMITTED ON
BEHALF OF DESHAUN WATSON.
THEN THERE'S A PERIOD OF TIME
THAT GOES BY A BRIEF IS
SUBMITTED ON BEHALF OF TONY
BUSBY'S CLIENTS IN EACH OF
THESE 21 CASES. THERE'S A
HEARING IN EACH OF THE 21
CASES THAT TAKES TIME. I
THINK WHAT'S GOING ON HERE
MILES IS THAT
RUSTY HARDEN HAS TAKEN THIS
APPROACH TO APPLY SETTLEMENT
PRESSURE TO TONY BUSBY IN
ORDER TO GET HIM TO COME TO
THE TABLE IN A CLEAR
PREDICTABLE LINEAR FASHION.
MY GUESS IS AND THIS IS JUST
A GUESS. MY GUESS IS THEY'VE
HAD A HARD TIME PINNING TONY
BUSBY DOWN REGARDING THE
POTENTIAL OF DISCUSSING
SETTLEMENT BECAUSE HE
UNDERSTANDS THE VALUE OF
AT THIS JUNCTURE OF THE
LITIGATION BECAUSE FROM
DESHAUN WATSON PERSPECTIVE TO
THE EXTENT THAT HE HAS HAD
HIS WAKE-UP CALL AND I WOULD
GUESS THAT HE HAS BY NOW,
ESPECIALLY AFTER TUESDAY'S
PRESS CONFERENCE THAT DESHAUN
WATSON IS WILLING AND READY
AND HE'S DEFINITELY ABLE TO
FIND A WAY TO REACH A
SETTLEMENT THAT IS ACCEPTABLE
TO EACH OF THESE 22
INDIVIDUALS AND MOVE ON WITH
HIS LIFE TAKE WHATEVER
PUNISHMENT THE LEAGUE OFFICE
MAY MEET OUT AGAINST HIM AND
I THINK AT THIS POINT WITH
THIS MANY CASES AND AFTER
BUT YOU CAN'T CLEAR THE DECKS.
YOU CAN'T MOVE FORWARD WITH
YOUR CAREER. YOU CAN'T GET
TRADED TO MIAMI OR WHEREVER
YOU WOULD LIKE TO BE TRADED
IF THIS LITIGATION IS GOING
TO LINGER AND LONGER AND
LONGER. SO BY HAVING THIS
HEARING TOMORROW BY TRYING TO
GET A RULING FROM THE JUDGE
THAT WOULD SAY ALL OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE TO EITHER
RELEASE THEIR NAMES OR GO
AWAY. BASICALLY THEN THAT IS
THE OCCASION FOR
SOME OF THEM MOST OF THEM BUT
NOT ALL OF THEM BECAUSE TWO
OF THEM HAVE ALREADY COME
FORWARD WITH THEIR NAMES TO
SIT DOWN AND TRY TO SETTLE
THESE CASES IF IT'S VALUABLE
TO THEM TO NEVER HAVE THEIR
NAMES DISCLOSED. THAT'S THE
KEY. THERE'S VALUE TO THEM IN
NOT HAVING THEIR NAMES
DISCLOSE THAT VALUE
TRANSLATES TO THE POTENTIAL
TO SETTLE THE CASE. I REALLY
DO THINK THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT. THERE'S ALWAYS
SOMETHING GOING ON BEHIND
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE FRONT
LINES IN LITIGATION AND I
THINK BEHIND THE SCENES
THEY'RE TRYING TO PIN DOWN
TONY BUSBY AND THIS IS THE
WAY TO PRESSURE HIM.
TO COME TO THE TABLE AND HAVE
A MEANINGFUL DISCUSSION. SO
DESHAUN WATSON CAN TRY TO GET
THIS SETTLED SO HE CAN GET
TRADED TO A TEAM OTHER THAN
THE TEXANS AND MOVE ON WITH
HIS CAREER AFTER HE HAS HIS
RECKONING. HE MAKES AMENDS
WITH EVERYONE INVOLVED AND
THEN TAKES WHATEVER
PUNISHMENT HE'S GOING TO GET
FROM 345 PARK AVENUE. WELL,
RIGHT THERE'S GOING TO BE
SOME SORT OF ACCOUNTABILITY
FROM THE LEAGUE OFFICE AND
THEN HE HAS TO TAKE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR HIS OWN
ACTIONS AND WHATEVER THAT
FORM THAT MAY TAKE AND
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT CIVIL SUITS WHICH IS
WHAT WE ARE IN SETTLEMENTS
THAN THAT FORM IS GOING TO AT
LEAST BE MONEY AND I THINK AT
LEAST AT THIS POINT BECAUSE
OF THE WAY THE COURT OF
PUBLIC OPINION HAS GONE. I
GUESS WE CAN SAY RIGHT NOW,
ESPECIALLY AFTER THE PRESS
CONFERENCE WITH ASHLEY SOLIS.
I MEAN, YOU CAN'T TELL ME
THAT ANYBODY WHO WOULD WATCH
THAT PRESS CONFERENCE THAT
WOULD LISTEN TO WHAT SHE HAD
TO SAY THAT ANYONE WOULD READ
WHAT SHE HAD TO SAY WOULD NOT
BE COMPELLED BY THAT. I MEAN,
IT WAS JUST VERY VERY
COMPELLING AS A STATEMENT.
I THINK JUST BASED
STAFF OF ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT THINGS THERE HAS TO
BE SOME SORT OF
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT HE HAS TO
TAKE IN ORDER FOR NOT ONLY
HIM TO MOVE ON BUT JUST FOR
THE LEAGUE OFFICE TO THEN SAY,
OKAY, HERE'S WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE PUNISHMENT IS
GOING TO BE OUT OF THAT AND I
THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE ONE
OF THE MOST INTERESTING
THINGS THAT COMES OUT OF THIS
BECAUSE HOW DO YOU EVEN START
TO QUANTIFY? WHAT A
PUNISHMENT SHOULD BE WHEN YOU
HAVE THIS MANY CASES AND THEN
SOME OF THEM OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE SETTLED
MAYBE NOT ALL OF THEM WILL BE
IT'S A
A VERY VERY COMPLEX SITUATION
AT LEAST IN MY READING OF IT
AND HERE'S ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT SETTLEMENT HAS VALUE TO
DESHAUN WATSON AND WHY TONY
BUSBY MAY PUT HIS THUMB ON
THE SCALE AND THIS IS ALL
LEGITIMATE. LOOK WHEN YOU ARE
TRYING TO ACQUIRE JUSTICE FOR
YOUR CLIENTS CASH EQUALS
JUSTICE THE BIGGER THE
SETTLEMENT THE BIGGER THE
VERDICT THE MORE JUSTICE
YOU'VE ACQUIRED FOR YOUR
CLIENT AND FOR THE LAWYERS
WHO HANDLE CASES LIKE THIS,
YOU'VE SEEN THE TV
COMMERCIALS. WE DON'T GET
PAID UNLESS WE GET MONEY.
IF YOU REMEMBER WHEN I WAS A
KID AND THE LITIGATION BOOM
FIRST STARTED AND I WAS VERY
CONFUSED. LIKE WAIT A MINUTE.
YOU DON'T GET PAID YOU DON'T
GET ANYTHING UNLESS YOU
SETTLE WELL, THAT'S NOT A
VERY SMART WAY TO GO ABOUT
YOUR BUSINESS. WHAT HAPPENS
IS YOU GET A PIECE OF THE
RECOVERY. THAT'S YOUR
INCENTIVE. THAT'S WHAT KEEPS
YOUR DOORS OPEN. THAT'S WHAT
PAYS YOUR OVERHEAD. THAT'S
WHAT ALLOWS YOU IF YOU'RE
TONY BUSBY TO HAVE A
ROLLS-ROYCE OR A BENTLEY OR
WHATEVER THAT ONE CAR IS. IT
WAS IN A AN AIRPORT GETTING
OUT OF AND IT'S FERRARI AND
YOU KNOW HIS RANCH AND ALL
THIS HE'S MADE MONEY. HE'S
BEEN EFFECTIVE. HE BOASTS TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN RECOVERY
FOR HIS CLIENTS OVER THE
YEARS. YOU ONLY TAKE ON CASES
WHERE YOU CAN PROVE LIABILITY
THERE IS SIGNIFICANT DAMAGES
AND YOU KNOW THAT THE PERSON
YOU'RE SUING HAS THE MONEY TO
PAY. THAT'S WHAT YOU DO AND
YOU JACK UP THE PRICE AS BEST
YOU CAN AND WHEN YOU HAVE A
TIGER BY THE TAIL LIKE HE
DOESN'T DESHAUN WATSON YOU
PULL UNTIL YOU GET THE
MAXIMUM RECOVERY FOR YOUR
CLIENT AND THERE'S VALUE HERE
HE CAN GIVE ON BEHALF OF HIS
CLIENT SMILES AND THIS TIES
BACK TO WHAT THE NFL CAN OR
CAN'T DO HE CAN GIVE TO
DESHAUN WATSON A COMMITMENT
THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS WON'T
COOPERATE AND I KNOW THAT
SEEMS A LITTLE SKEEVY AND CD
AND WRONG, BUT THAT THAT'S
FAIR ITS PROPER
CONFIDENTIALITY AGREEMENT NDA.
THIS IS PART OF WHAT YOU
BARGAINED FOR. THESE
INDIVIDUALS WILL NOT
COOPERATE COOPERATE WITH THE
NFL IS ONE OF THE BIG FLAWS
IN THE NFL'S INVESTIGATIVE
PROCESS MILES. THEY CAN'T
COMPEL ANYONE TO TALK OTHER
THAN DESHAUN WATSON NOW,
THAT DOESN'T STOP.
THEM FROM BRINGING IN DESHAUN
WATSON AND ASKING EXTENSIVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHY IN THE
WORLD. DO YOU HAVE 40
DIFFERENT PEOPLE GIVING YOU
MASSAGES AND WAS THERE
CONSENSUAL SEX THAT HAPPENED
AT THESE AND WHAT'S YOUR
VERSION IN RESPONSE TO THESE
ALLEGATIONS, BUT IF YOU DON'T
HAVE COOPERATION OF THE
ALLEGED VICTIMS MAKES A
LITTLE BIT DIFFICULT TO HAVE
A SIGNIFICANT PUNISHMENT
UNDER THE PERSONAL CONDUCT
POLICY, BUT THINK BACK TO BEN
ROETHLISBERGER. HE GOT
SUSPENDED ULTIMATELY FOUR
GAMES FOR BEING SUED FOR RAPE
IN NEVADA THAT NEVER WAS
RESOLVED IN COURT I ASSUME IT
WAS SETTLED AT SOME POINT. I
RECALL IT'S ONE OF THOSE
THINGS THAT WAS SO LONG AGO.
I FORGET BUT IT NEVER WENT TO
COURT. HE WAS PUNISHED BEFORE
IT EVER WOULD HAVE GONE TO
COURT AND THEN HE HAD THE
INCIDENT IN GEORGIA IN EARLY
2010 THAT NEVER WAS A LAWSUIT
NEVER WAS AN ARREST NEVER WAS
ANYTHING AND HE GOT SUSPENDED
FOUR GAMES FOR TO HEAR YOU
GOT 22. GOOD LUCK. IF YOU
THE NFL COMING UP WITH THE
RIGHT PUNISHMENT FOR DESHAUN
WATSON. I STILL THINK THERE'S
CHANCE HE FACES A
SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANT
PUNISHMENT, BUT YOU CAN'T EVEN
THE POINT WHERE THE NFL'S
READY TO PUNISH YOU WHILE
THESE CASES ARE PENDING. HE
COULD BE OUT OF ACTION FOR A
YEAR OR TWO AND THEN GET
PUNISHED ON THE BACK END. SO
THIS IS HIS BEST MOVE, RIGHT
AND THAT'S WHAT I THINK THE
COMMISSIONERS EXEMPT LISTS IS
FOR RIGHT AND YOU KNOW,
YOU'VE BEEN CALLING FOR THIS
WILL LAST COUPLE OF DAYS THAT
HE NEEDS TO IMMEDIATELY GO ON
THE COMMISSIONERS EXEMPT LIST
BECAUSE LOOK THE TEXANS HAVE
ENOUGH PROBLEMS ALREADY. I
MEAN WE CAN SAY THAT FROM A
FOOTBALL STANDPOINT NOW WE
SAY IT FROM A DESHAUN WATSON
STANDPOINT THAT THEY
DON'T NECESSARILY
WE NEED THE CIRCUS OF ALSO
HAVING TO ANSWER FOR
SOMETHING WHERE THEY REALLY
CAN'T SAY VERY MUCH OF
ANYTHING BECAUSE I MEAN LOOK
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY ON THE
TEXANS WHAT DESHAUN WATSON
HAS DONE IN HIS PERSONAL TIME.
HOWEVER, HE IS STILL AN
EMPLOYEE OF THE HOUSTON
TEXANS. SO AT A CERTAIN POINT,
YES, THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ASKED QUESTIONS ABOUT IT, BUT
I THINK JUST FROM WHATEVER
STANDPOINT WHERE WE'RE AT
RIGHT NOW. THERE'S NO REASON
FOR JOHN WATSON TO BE
ANYWHERE NEAR A FOOTBALL
FACILITY AT THIS.
IN TIME AND THE ONLY THE BEST
WAY TO DO THAT IS TO PUT HIM
ON THE COMMISSIONERS EXEMPT
LIST, AND NOW THERE'S STILL A
COUPLE OF WEEKS OR A WEEK OR
TWO ACTUALLY DON'T KNOW WHEN
APRIL 19TH IS BECAUSE I DON'T
KNOW WHAT DAY IT IS BECAUSE
TIME IS AN ILLUSION AT THIS
POINT IN MY LIFE, BUT THAT'S
WHEN THE OFFSEASON PROGRAM IS
SUPPOSED TO BEGIN. SO A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME BEFORE
THAT SO THEY DON'T HAVE TO DO
THIS IMMEDIATELY, BUT IT'S
ALMOST LIKE I FEEL LIKE IT'S
SOMETHING THAT COULD BE A
FRIDAY NEWS DUMP TOMORROW
WHERE WE'RE ABOUT TO GET ON
THE AIR OR WE'RE ALREADY ON
THE AIR MIKE AND THEN WE ALL
YEAH.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
HAPPENED BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO
DO SOMETHING TO JUST DO
SOMETHING AT THIS POINT. HOW
DO YOU NOT KNOW WHAT DAY IT
IS? IT'S APRIL 8 THE
SIX-MONTH COUNTDOWN TO YOUR
30TH BIRTHDAY. IT'S NOT BUT
DID I GET IT? I GET IT. DID I
GET IT? I TRY NO, BUT YOU'RE
GOING TO TRY YOUR IN THE
WORLD PARKER. YOU'RE NOT
QUITE RIGHT. THE WALLS ARE
CLOSING IN WE'RE EVENTUALLY
GOING TO GET THERE. WE'RE
GOING TO FIGURE OUT WHEN
MILES BIRTHDAY IS ALL RIGHT.
YEAH, I AND ANOTHER POINT.
HAVE SEEN ALIVE AND I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THIS I DON'T KNOW
THIS BUT I BELIEVE THAT
DESHAUN WATSON IF THESE CASES
ARE STILL LINGERING WHEN
TRAINING CAMP STARTS, YOU
KNOW, WE HAVE BEEN
CONDITIONED TO BELIEVE
THERE'S NO WAY HE'S SHOWING
UP. THERE'S NO WAY HE'S
SHOWING UP. I THINK HE'S
SHOWING UP IF HE'S NOT
ALREADY ON THE COMMISSIONER
EXAMPLE LIST. I THINK HE'S
SHOWING UP BECAUSE YOU HOLD
OUT YOU DON'T PLAY YOU GIVE
UP 20 MILLION IN FINES
FORFEITURE SALARY
YOU SHOW UP YOU
GET PUT ON THE COMMISSIONER
EXEMPT LIST. YOU GET PAID 10
MILLION PLUS IN SALARY TO NOT
PLAY FOR THE TEXANS. SO
CIRCUMSTANCES HAVE CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY FOR DESHAUN
WATSON AND I THINK HE WILL BE
THERE IF HE'S NOT ALREADY PUT
ON THE COMMISSIONER EXEMPT
LIST, BUT AS I SAID YESTERDAY
MILES, I KNOW WHAT THE NFL'S
STRATEGY IS. THERE'S NO
REASON TO CREATE A MAJOR
HEADLINE AND FL PUTS DESHAUN
WATSON ON PAID LEAVE. NO
REASON TO DO IT IN THE OFF
SEASON WHEN THERE'S NOTHING
TO BE PUT ON LEAVE FROM BUT
I THINK AT SOME POINT IT'S ON
THE
FELL TO REACT IN A WAY THAT
IS STRONGER THAN ISSUING THE
PERFUNCTORY STATEMENT THAT
SAYS WE'RE DEEPLY DISTURBED
BY THE ALLEGATIONS.
EVERYONE'S DEEPLY DISTURBED
BY THE ALLEGATIONS. THAT'S
NOT GOOD ENOUGH. I THINK WHAT
THE NFL NEEDS TO DO HERE WHAT
IT HAS AN OBLIGATION TO DO IN
ORDER TO PROVE THAT IT TAKES
THIS SERIOUSLY IS DO IT. NOW
PUT THEM ON THE COMMISSIONER
EXAMPLE IS NOW PENDING THE
RESOLUTION OF ALL OF THESE
CASES BECAUSE THEN I THINK
WHAT IT DOES IS IT KIND OF
TAKES OFF THE TABLE THIS
WHOLE BEAT THE CLOCK IDEA OF
WHAT?
YOU KNOW WHAT WE GOT TO GET
THIS DONE BEFORE HE'S PUT ON
THE COMMISSIONER EXAMPLES
LOOK PUT HIM ON THE
COMMISSIONER EXAMPLES LOOK
PUT HIM ON THE COMMISSIONER
EXEMPT LIST ALLOW THESE CASES
TO PLAY OUT IF A SETTLEMENTS
GOING TO HAPPEN. SO BE IT IF
NOT FIGHT IT BUT BUT WE DON'T
HAVE THIS WORRY OF WELL, YOU
KNOW, YOU BETTER GO AHEAD AND
WRITE A BIG CHECK BECAUSE
OTHERWISE THEY'RE GOING TO
PUT YOU ON THE COMMISSIONER
EXAMPLES, YOU CAN SAY THEY
ALREADY DID SO WE CAN SET
THAT ASIDE AND LET'S FOCUS
ABOUT WHAT'S RIGHT FOR
EVERYONE SO WE CAN GET THESE
CASES RESOLVED. EXACTLY AND
THAT'S THAT'S I THINK THE
BIGGEST THING IS THAT IT HAS
TO BE
SOMETHING.
WATSON. THAT'S I THINK AT THE
FOREFRONT OF MY MIND WHEN YOU
GET THESE KINDS OF
ALLEGATIONS, IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE THE
BEST THING FOR HIM. BUT I
THINK FOR THE ORGANIZATION
FOR THE THE PEOPLE WHO HE
ALLEGEDLY ASSAULTED. THESE
ARE THE PEOPLE WHO WE GOT TO
KEEP IN MIND AND I THINK THAT
BY DOING THIS IT'S BETTER FOR
EVERYBODY INVOLVED BECAUSE
LIKE YOU SAID, THERE'S NO
RACE AGAINST THE CLOCK THERE
IS NO OH NO, THIS IS ABOUT
TRAINING CAMP IS ABOUT TO
THAT SO I THINK IT ALSO CUT
IF YOU LOOK AT IT FROM THE
LEAGUE OFFICE STANDPOINT. IT
ALSO KIND OF TAKES THAT
DECISION OUT OF THE HANDS OF
THE HOUSTON TEXANS WHO WOULD
ASSUME I WOULD MAYBE ASSUME
SAY LIKE HEY, YOU CAN
PROBABLY STAY AWAY FROM ANY
OFFSEASON ACTIVITY MANDATORY
MINICAMP TRAINING CAMP. WHAT
HAVE YOU UNTIL THESE CASES
ARE RESOLVED, RIGHT? SO IF
YOU DO THAT FROM THE LEAGUE
OFFICE, IT ALSO TAKES THAT
PRESSURE OFF OF THE HOUSTON
TEXANS. I THINK THAT THAT IS
JUST THE WAY TO DO IT FOR
EVERYBODY INVOLVED TO SHOW
THAT HEY WE'RE TAKING THIS
SERIOUSLY, AND ALSO WE KNOW
THAT THERE HAS TO EVENTUALLY
BE SOME SORT OF RESOLUTION IN
SOME SORT OF ACCOUNTABILITY
AND THIS IS KIND OF OUR
AVENUE OF MAKING SURE THAT
THAT CAN HAPPEN WITHOUT
DESHAUN WATSON BEING ON A
ROSTER CURRENTLY AND TEXANS
WOULD HAVE A VERY STRONG
REASON TO WANT EVERYTHING TO
GET RESOLVED. SO THEY COULD
TRADE DESHAUN WATSON AND NOT
PAY HIM ANYTHING THIS YEAR
AND GET VALUE IN RETURN FOR
THE HEARINGS ARE TOMORROW.
THERE'S AT LEAST TWO OF THEM
AND I BELIEVE THIS IS ABOUT
FORCING TONY BUSBY TO THE
TABLE TO TRY TO SETTLE THESE
CASES BEFORE THE DRAFT AND
THE HOPES OF GETTING TO SEAN
WATSON TRADED BEFORE THE
DRAFT. THERE'S STILL HOPE IF
THEY CAN DO THIS AND AGAIN IN
SAYING IT. I'M NOT SUGGESTING
THAT THE SEAN WATSON PAY HUSH
MONEY OR MAKE IT GO AWAY OR
YOU KNOW, LOOK HE NEEDS TO
STAND UP TAKE HIS RECKONING
MAKE THINGS RIGHT WITH EACH
OF THESE 22 INDIVIDUALS. IT'S
TBUO T DOI  THINK Y
NBUEET DSI  TTHO INDOK  IHET  E